the United States called the security
council meeting on the role of conflict
in fueling food insecurity at a time
when Global food prices are rising
Secretary of State Anthony blinken
announced 362 million dollars in new
funding for Haiti and 11 African
countries noting that grain prices have
increased 8 percent since Russia pulled
out of the Black Sea grain initiative
and began bombing Ukrainian ports the
initiative was meant to protect food
shipments leaving Ukraine and Russia
every member of the United Nations
should tell Moscow
enough
enough using the Black Sea as blackmail
treating the world's most vulnerable
people as Leverage
enough
of this unjustified
unconscionable War but Russia whose
President Vladimir Putin recently met
with African leaders and promised to
send free grain to six of them pointed a
finger back at the United States
it's hard not to notice that the amount
of assistance provided by the US and its
allies to the countries of the global
South cannot be compared to what the
West has spent on weapons in less than
two years for its proxy war
the world food program has seen its
costs increase by nearly 50 percent in
the last year and funding for
humanitarian assistance has not kept
pace forcing some hard decisions for Aid
workers they are struggling with
critical funding shortfalls and are only
able to reach 50 percent of the need
they are faced with the impossible
decision of which half of the children
can live
and which half will be sentenced to
death
African countries are among those hurt
most by Rising food prices
Mozambique
calls on the security Council
to do all in its power
towards achieving a cessation of
hostilities in all conflicts that
continue to claim human lives
all Security Council Members agree in
principle food should not be used as a
weapon of War they even signed a
statement saying as much but today's
comments suggests it will have little
impact on those conflicts currently
causing the most harm
Kristen salumi Al Jazeera the United
Nations